how many bodies is too many bodies for a
girl one one
what are you guys's body count zero zero
that's crazy everyone I interview is a
virgin there are a lot of virgins in
London I'm not from London so me too
sleeping around different for men and
for women it shouldn't be no it is but
it shouldn't be
said like
percent yeah it shouldn't be different
yes it is no okay why why yes why no
well no I say it's different because of
the perception of people if you sleep
around as a woman you're a [__] if you
sleep around as a man you're good what's
the basis of the question which is
basically what you said you're saying it
shouldn't matter
better yeah I say the same I'm just
saying in reality it does matter yeah in
reality what do I think
no I'll I'll tell you I try to have
conversations I mean I think it does
matter if you look at the data like okay
if a girl slept with zero people and
she's a virgin do you know what her
chances of having a happy marriage
eighty percent if she slept with more
than five it drops to twenty percent
so it's like when I'm looking at this
and this is self-reported how do I argue
with that go ahead where is the
statistics on that so it's a study that
was done in the U.S and and they would
they would ask women how what's their
what you okay slightly different so so
they've done they've done similar
studies with women on like other things
like like higher rates of depression
higher rates of like like it all kind of
goes together I think body count matters
I don't think it matches I shouldn't
stopped me from like wanting to be in a
relationship with someone but I do like
look at it and be like hmm like I do
kind of no I don't think you're muscles
no everyone is just what you're
comfortable with what the person's
comfortable with so if it doesn't matter
would you guys say your body counts yeah
yeah well mine's literally one so there
we go one and proud zero yeah
everyone I've talked to is a virgin
today
a version or three or less but it's just
the only reason I ask is because it's
like we say it doesn't matter but
oftentimes they don't want to say yeah
yeah no that's
okay
I'm transparent what am I good like it's
nothing yeah it's not a big deal yeah I
don't think it makes someone like less
of a person at all I do I just I just
think like it's harder for women if
we've experienced more to be happy with
the one we have because we compare yeah
I agree with that and I've seen a lot of
girls like where they're in love with
their ex but what they're with the new
guy what is your personal experience
with what
what the
um I get mixed answers some people say
it matters some people say it doesn't
I'm not saying I'm right or I'm wrong
it's going to change in five years
and what are you my my question
no I think it'll
work do I think it'll change what
yeah yeah I have an ex-boyfriend yeah
yeah
um it was a couple years
[Music]
no I'm not with him now we broke up
a couple years
yeah
oh I'm 25.
what
123 when you had this relationships
yeah yes okay yes what that does it make
you
want to ask that question and at this
point
um people typically give me like more
honest answers I haven't been here
before I'm lucky to sleep around for
this body for sure have you been here to
the festival no this is my first time
I've never I've never heard of it this
is someone told me about it I should do
interviews here without a doubt I think
you should have two out of three you
have to attend two years and that's the
same question as we're gonna talk to a
guy and he said I slept with 50 women
would you care no it wouldn't lie
um I wouldn't like make that stop me
from being with him but I would I think
because I'm very respectful about
sleeping people I'd be a bit like I
would probably fall a bit lower I would
like I'd be a bit apprehensive like if
you gave me a reason why I sort of like
what was your mentality doing that was
it just to earn more women or was it
because you liked them or sort of like
it just depends on the person well it's
kind of like you don't have the same
values in a way yeah yeah pretty much
overall though it's not a big deal but
if yeah it's a values thing yeah do you
think it's bad if a guy says he doesn't
want a girl that slept with so many
people yes yeah I think that's bad
yeah if he's got if he's also got a low
body count and so do I let's say I don't
think it's a big deal but if you stay
with 40 girls and then I've sat with
like one guy and you're like oh I don't
want you to do that but I think that's
just stupid like yeah
do you think sleeping around is
different for men and for women both you
shouldn't be sleeping around that's
disgusting ew how many bodies is too
many bodies in a way is I don't think
Body Matters if you really like the
person I don't think Body Matters you
don't think it matters I don't think it
matters no what's your body my body cow
body cows I can't really say that no the
only the only reason I ask is because a
lot of times we'll say it doesn't matter
but no one ever wants to say it no of
course there was his name it doesn't
really matter it only matters if you're
actually talking with a person yeah and
then you're out here doing [__] [__]
yeah like you know you're not supposed
to be doing that but if it was before
you met him you don't care or her I
don't care because I wasn't around I
wasn't around you know what I'm saying
so do you think it's okay for men to
care about that stuff
something deep but you know I don't know
I can't really ask that question because
you know I'm not a man you know it's
just a lot of times like girls will say
they shouldn't care but they do so I
don't care personally because I didn't
know you way back before so it's like
you know what I'm saying but if you're
in a relationship with me or talking to
me I don't expect you to be talking to
someone else you know what I mean like
we'll be doing stuff with someone else
has that happened I don't really care if
that happens body count has that
happened to me no way
no no it hasn't happened to me no so you
rate yourself one to ten I'm a 10 out of
10. what does the cameraman think
ing all right
I'll rate you all right I give you I
give you eight actually
10 10 means you're perfect I don't think
I think I think you're like pretty
enough you could model oh thank you so
much
all right
number five
I'm gonna give myself a 10 because
self-love you think that because I I
asked this and this is like a common
answer I get today don't you think 10
means you're perfect don't we all have
room for improvement yes well I think
you can always make room I think it
counts do you think sleeping around is
different for men and for women do you
think sleeping around is different for
men and for women oh gosh I mean
definitely because men can just go
around and do whatever they want then at
the same time we're all human like I get
to a certain degree but when it's
different woman [__] 10 boys a boy
wouldn't want to go near her but if a
man did it wouldn't be it would be fine
actually I've interviewed people on this
today 10 is right when you become not
wifey it's like at the 10 to 15 Mark
they're like nah if it was a boy it'd be
different yes why I think think women I
think when they do it it's more
emotional than when men do it I think
when men do it they're more thinking
about how they're going to feel
physically more than mentally and women
are more looking for an emotional
connection rather than something
physical I think that it is different
but it's starting to be normalized that
women can sleep with as many men as they
want to just now I think within the last
five years with the rise of Holly people
are more open to it but I think before
yeah it would be really different it
would be shunned upon because how many
bodies there's too many bodies for you
to date someone
I don't think any really like I think
I'm not it should be that wouldn't so do
you think body count matters if if I'm
not gonna lie if I'm being honest if it
was really extensive then yeah I'd be a
bit slightly a bit more cautious in that
regard but I feel you can't just judge
on someone because of their bodycon I
just think that's a bit